all right ladies and gentlemen thank you
for tuning in again to your local
locksmith urban locking key coming at
you with another programming video today
we are working on a
looks like
2018 jeep compass
2018 jeep compass programming a four
button smart key
uh for certain models in certain years
it does require to have the bypass
gateway key a big gateway cable
set up
in this case it does not so we're going
to go ahead and get the
vehicle powered up
all right
first thing we're going to do and we're
also using an auto pad pro light
we're going to go into us chrysler
hit agree
you can auto id or search by vehicle i
like to search by vehicle because
chrysler jeep and dodge they pick up
faster that way this is a 2018 go to
2018 20 model
now read carefully it gives you a
description
hit ok
you're going to go to programming keys
turn the hazards on
turn the ignition off
come back and press ok
it's going to tell you what to do
and just follow the instructions play
smart key near start stop button then
press the unlike button once within 30
seconds
and
success
all right
as you can tell this key is now
functional
okay
thank you for tuning in to your local
locksmith coming at you
stay tuned for more videos